[Music]
this is the MIT compared to media
studies in writing podcast
I'm Andrew Whitaker let's jump right on
into this week's recording with Mount
Holyoke College is Kimberly brown with
just the mention that next Friday May
18th we have our last event of the
semester when our science writing grad
students present their theses that is
open to the public too so join us on the
MIT student center between 10 a.m. and 5
p.m. and we'll live streaming on our
YouTube channel check si MSW mit.edu for
details now on to Professor Brown and
her talk on US media coverage especially
photography of the final year of South
African apartheid
[Music]
Holyoke College
her research engages decided that visual
as a way to negotiate the parameters of
race gender and belonging and her book
repeated bodies slavery's visual
resonance in the contemporary examines
slavery's profound ocular construction
and the presence of absence of seeing in
relation to the plantation space and the
women who exist in their 2015 there been
among us photography politics New York
Times in 1994 for for geography South
Africa on to Rwanda Sudan and Haiti and
this year she is the motor King jr.
visiting assistant professor who stood
by my thank you so I want to thank the
comparative Media Studies Writing
Program for inviting me to give what is
my final MIT Talk
and thank you all for being here today I
really appreciate it uh there will be a
few graphic images I will not show them
for very long can everyone hear me good
there's a photograph from 1993 that I've
been thinking about since 2006 when I
first saw it I've written about it and
I've often returned to it as a point of
origin for my current research project
people who know me know that I spend
what I consider to be a great deal of
time fixating on one still image until I
know what it's trying to tell me this
photograph is still speaking to me for
the difficult work it engages the absent
of global anti-blackness it presents and
the implications it has for those who
view it it is a difficult image to see
in March 1993 white South African
photographer Kevin Carter travels to
what is now South Sudan to photograph
the civil war taking place there he
happens upon a sight that arrests him
and he uses his camera to document it a
vulture patiently waiting as a child
struggles to make it to a food camp a
kilometer away in the next few months
the image will become a symbol of the
devastation that war brings to ordinary
humans he will win the Pulitzer Prize
but viewers will have questions about
the ethics of photographing the
suffering of others and his answers will
be insufficient and so here we're going
to have one of his friends and his
former girlfriend talk about this
critique that people have of the image
yeah took out of mine she realized the
other side of the point that a lot of
people wasn't seeing this great image of
one's breath as I see has kept him
finally to say thank you let this event
each other play today especially the
catalyst for change
and therefore the people actually
contracting cheering you how teacher I
was their first Eagle it was mainly
involved
[Music]
disrupting alignment whose kids don't
have a channel I have shots from spools
of foam that he took in on that same
assignment they taught Easterner learn
to show its skin supposed to go they on
a mission of mercy he's there as a
photographer he's gotta keep his
emotions in check and do his job and
he's with older men leaning into them
he knows absolutely contestant Lee near
a mission station that he was so
pleasant picked up that child and he got
played and really he whipped other
comments you shattered I want to spend a
moment here I could spend several talks
just going through that scene but I want
to spend a moment here to consider the
implications that exist within and
beyond the frame of the photograph if
that picture hadn't played today we
still wouldn't know how to spell Sudan
and then the he wept over comments he
was shattered in the 2005 documentary
the death of Kevin Carter casualty of
the bangbang Club director Dan Kraus
interviews photo journalists writers and
editors who worked for news media
outlets during the violent decades of
apartheid what strikes me each time I
watched the film is more than ten years
after the end of the regime there is
such a lack of racial self-reflection by
the participants Johannesburg is
described as a romantic space of tension
and excitement that abruptly
recalibrates itself in order to make
room for another possibility that
possibility is foreclosed since it since
it would necessitate intimacy's that
have at the very least 50 years of
structured refusal but then again these
people are also mourning they are
mourning the loss of one of their own
Carter who committed suicide months
after receiving the Pulitzer for what
will always be his most
famous photograph when trying to think
about what divides the space of
photographic possibility from one viewer
to another
I remember the photograph is intertwined
with this documentary and so it's first
the poster that I saw didn't know that
there was a documentary about Carter
watch the documentary about a year after
I found out about the photograph and
then decided out I was going to write
about this image of course this
consideration is for the benefit of
others to photograph is to frame Susan
Sontag rights and to frame is to exclude
excluded from this photograph through
the eventual understanding of Carters
psychological limitations is any
investment in the humanity of the child
it matters that a white South African
from a space of relative privilege
travels to Sudan and returns with this
image so this in part is what I've
written about this photograph and I'm
gonna read that section this photograph
boasts a long and voluptuous after
history through carter's authorship and
the illusion of a discourse of the awful
for the child through the photographs
duplication the image completes the
meta-narrative of oblivion that conquest
and empire civil unrest and geographical
circumstance have begun with this one
photograph famine has a savior and that
savior is the white witness
I ask myself often what is the desire
embedded in the presentation of images
like this one why is it that no matter
how many of these photographs circulate
there is always space for more as if
blackness aligned with death is an
unrelenting cycle of pleasure that white
supremacy demands and depends upon then
I ask myself about refusal abstraction
and the politics of the visual that we
live with today I try to locate my
ocular engagement within this space my
talk today is a continuation of this
engagement
what is the work of enclosure that
proximity engenders so the poster this
is the original poster the poster is
then updated I'm assuming people wrote
and said something to the directors of
the producers because a year later when
it was nominated for an Academy Award
it's a different poster entirely let you
see but both of these are still both
posters are still on the Internet
how have you errs been trained to see in
the sliver of space between one person
and another contemporary photographic
elision and mortalities hyper presence
because there is a failure of
understanding for everyone who's
interviewed in that 27 million minute
film to understand the subjectivity of
the girl in the photograph they are
really just there to think about Carter
and Carter's daughter who's I want to
say she's 16 at the time that she's
interviewed she's a small child when he
dies she says that the in her in her
mind the the world is the vulture and
the child is her father they we inhabit
knowledge that the black body is a sign
of imminent death kristina sharp writes
and in the wake on blackness and being
and with this immediacy comes a violent
repetition of fluid temporalities and a
discursive trajectory of movement and
stasis how are these images constructed
what progress do they refuse I'm moving
between these spaces temporal elongation
and quotidian frigidity fragility in
order to understand how global
obsolescence is articulated through
black embodiment decades mark south
africa's experiment with racial
apartheid through photography in ocular
conundrum from 1948 when the white
supremacist National Party is voted into
power until 1994 when apartheid
officially ends and Nelson Mandela is
elected president photography
centralizes the way the world learned
about the violence that accompanied the
apartheid regime since 1994 is a
significant year in South Africa's
racial trajectory
my book project which is currently just
called March of elam knows no semicolon
knows no : no after I don't think it'll
work but here we are
March of ism opens here in the JIRA in
the geographic space of fluctuating
sovereignties and mired in deep
interlocking histories in many ways a
shield and Bembe rights our world
remains a world of races whether we
admit it or not he continues although
this fact is often denied the racial
signifier is still in many ways the
inescapable language for the stories
people tell about themselves about their
relationship with the other about memory
and about power decades mark this
terrain of inescapable language with the
violence enacted by the apartheid regime
and thus pulls the viewer into the frame
gelatin silver print screen this time
presents South Africa as a space of
binary opposition black and white
negative and positive black and white
negative and positive something about
photography's originally construction
dark rooms interior versus exterior
reinforces a racialized binary that gets
played out symbolically this talk will
ponder the presence or lack thereof of
black subjectivity as it exists in the
ocular space of what I am calling the
march of evil
so I'm defining this in multiple ways
and this is just one of the ways that
I'm defining this project and defining
this term I I looked up the word for I
was looking for something that said live
forever and I came up I found some pervy
them and then I assumed mistakenly that
Morcha vivo already existed as a word
the more to be them in my definition is
the imagistic documentary dividing line
of deaths proximity to blackness that
must be continually negotiated by
artists writers and cultural
practitioners it is the voyage through
death to life upon these shores that
Robert Hayden's poem middle passage
presents as a thematic organizing
principle of slavery's life and
slavery's afterlife
some pervy them on the other hand orders
the structure of whiteness as the visual
corollary of a kind of racial elongation
of human life
the ocular production of the live
forever so the idea or the concept is
through the semper vivo
you know that why people are encased in
safety photographically because of who
is encased in the photograph not safe so
even though this is a really famous
lynching photograph and the bodies are
removed people know you know that this
is a lynching photograph right so people
know that this photograph exists and
they know that two black men are being
were murdered here opening in 2001 South
Africa's apartheid museum is the first
of its kind a kind of live forever
for a different sort located in
Johannesburg the museum's ambitious
design is meant to signal the better
future of a post apartheid world inside
the structure
visitors are meant to experience the
racial stratification of the regime as
soon as they enter the museum and
mission cards produce a binary of white
and non-white identity in order to
critique apartheid classification system
your ticket to the museum has randomly
classified you as either white or
non-white the ticket holder is informed
they are then instructed to use the
entrance to the museum in accordance
with a ticket classification the
entrances are separated by this binary
logic and so visitors immediately
perform privilege or racial subjugation
based on the statistical whimsy of an
entrance card and I found it striking
that months later I couldn't remember if
I had to go through the white or
non-white doorway and then I am assuming
that it was non-white because I would
have remembered if it were white I think
but it was striking to me that I didn't
I couldn't remember which makes me think
it was the non-white door so you go
through the two doors white or non-white
and you end up in the same place so I'm
not really sure how it's supposed to
function as an experiment
the second person allows for a familiar
intimacy to float just above the surface
hover close at hand with an uncanny
ability to reinforce the very hierarchy
it purports to deconstruct white
visitors in a ubiquitous consolidation
may have their whiteness reified by an
experiment in memory making that
rhetorically orders what was initially a
juridical practice 2001 seven years
after the end of the apartheid regime a
museum opens to relegate the system to
the past and it is still participating
in this endeavor and so here I will say
that I am probably not the best person
to ask because I do not know what the
solution is supposed to be when you're
trying to address the trauma of
particular subjectivity but you're also
trying to make sure that enough people
come through the museum space and
experience it I don't know how this is
supposed to be done what I have seen in
the few spaces that attempt to do this
work is that they still seem to be
invested in white comfort and so to me
it cannot really function as it's
supposed to function if white people are
entering this space and they're still
feeling very comfortable and there were
a few black people in the museum the day
that I went I think we were all tourists
and I asked my taxi driver when I was
going back to the hotel if he had been
to this museum and he laughed and I did
not expect that and then he asked me how
much it cost to get in there so it turns
out that how much it cost is like I want
to say 25 percent of the monthly salary
of your average black South African so I
don't think that they intend for them to
enter that space with any meaningful
engagement the temporal framework
the temporal framework of apartheid is
the second half of the 20th century a
precise visual location through which to
process the photography of
anti-blackness projected against a world
stage for nearly 50 years documentary
photographs punctuated media coverage of
the violence that apartheid engendered
from forced removals in places like
Sofia town the stripping away of
citizenship rights for black South
Africans Afrikaans being chosen as the
official language in schools the
renaming of geographies from indigenous
African names to Dutch European names
the ceaseless murders beatings and
arrests it's a precise marking that
troubles the discourse embedded within
namely histories of Empire African
Studies visual culture studies Black
Studies and Gender Studies it is too
trouble what Tina camp calls the lower
frequencies of Transfiguration enacted
at the level of the quotidian in the
everyday traffic of black folks with
objects that are both mundane and
special photographs so I decided not to
show you these photographs because they
are so graphic and because when I
visited the museum I was struck and
that's the second time I interacted with
apartheid images videos and photographs
but I was struck by how many graphic
images of black people were being shown
and almost none or none that I saw of
white people in any state of corporeal
injury or destruction right so that also
I didn't know what to do with that so I
decided not to show any of those images
my current book project engages the
relationship between photography black
subjectivity and Empire and these are
the chapters so far the book examines
images of the dead in the New York Times
from four geographies South Africa
Rwanda Sudan and Haiti I focused on a
single year in 1994 in order to grapple
with a register of photographic
residents moving from the 19th century
through the 20th century my project will
consider the place of melancholy when
the subject of mourning is black this
means I am
then asked to read beyond an assumed
viewership in order to find this
register more chewy even constructs the
advent of photography as uniquely
positioned to produce the fungibility to
use cydia Hartman's term that manages to
continually frame the contours of black
subjectivity for the book project I'm
interested in how viewers of media
imagery receive and process images of
the dead particularly when those in the
photographs of the dead and dying or
black so I'm often asking people if they
can remember a time when someone in the
last 2025 years when someone who is
would be read as white was on the cover
of a daily newspaper that they could
remember dead and so far people go back
to like Holocaust they go back to like
1940s and not not anything since then so
far so it's not to say that it doesn't
exist it's just that people can't
remember because that's not what happens
here so for the project the vast
majority of images of dead people come
from Haiti the fewest from Rwanda so
there's nobody there during the time
taking photographs so everything is
after the genocide takes place and for
Haiti
it's a US intervention Haiti militaries
they're photographers are there what I
am calling a cartography of the ocular
moving from national location to
national location but always under the
cover of blackness has very specific
dimensions a viable and recognizable
enemy the failure of other people's
sovereignty and the ability to reinforce
imperial domination across the world
this cartography defines the
compartments of a centralizing question
of this project is the visuality of
violence against black subjects germane
to the structure of modern humanity do
we need to see it all the time within
the unsettling history of photography in
the United States for instance images of
the other temporally defined situate the
world of those who belong in stark
contrast to those who do not usually it
is corporeal display that creates this
chasm wrapping the world of belonging
and unbel awning around
contours of a photographic print by the
end of the 19th century a ready
viewership is eager to evaluate analyze
and dissect marking reservoirs of
meaning within each specified category
photography came to establish and
delimit the terrain of the other islands
of Kula rights to define both the
generalized look the typology and the
contingent insistence of deviance and
social pathology the social and moral
hierarchy according to Sakhalin that
develops in the first few decades of
photography divides itself between the
public and the private sphere between
quote private the private moment of
sentimental individuation and to other
more public looks a look up at one's
betters and a look down at once
inferiors in quote so cool is commenting
on the emergence in the 19th century of
the visually regulated figure of
criminal suspicion and the police
photography that enhanced the
particularity zuv acceptable citizenship
the rise of eugenics alongside
photography in the latter part of the
19th century made legible and multiple
the anxieties of Western modernity so
here is where I would say that my first
book is concerned with how slavery is
made palpable through black women's
bodies and it has a photographic
register in other words it's concerned
or interested in photography because
there is a way that contemporary
configurations of anti-black violence
don't exist with black women at the
center as if nothing ever happened to
black women and as if nothing will ever
happen to black women and we know this
to not be the case so like much of even
my first book is invested in what is
seen and what is unseen a denial of
vulnerability that has at its core a
desire to see black women as superhuman
so that slavery can be made palatable
its violence less visible so here also
is where I say that the process of
thinking through the evidentiary which
is usually where people goes say we need
these images because without these
images we will not know
what took place and I wonder about that
because the testimonies the documents
the images the way that black women and
black feminist scholars in particularly
or has endlessly try to present their
particular kind of productive deployment
of subjectivity and that is always
refused at some level I don't know that
that would be the case like I don't know
that evidence is the thing that marks
this space as evidentiary so we have now
that we've seen so many moving images of
black people dying in the United States
in particular it hasn't exactly proven
the point in any legal sense so I'm not
sure that that that is a thing that
works without my research and slavery
studies I might not have had to
contemplate the trajectory of movement
between slavery's demise and the
fungibility Sudhir Hartman presents as a
cloaking feature of black life those
moments of release and refusal the terms
of black subjectivity in the wake as
christina sharp names them asked of us
that we offer interpretations that
preserve the humanity of the subjects
that we study more to leave them traces
of the history of photography from its
emergence in the 19th century to its
digital facilitation at the end of the
20th century this is a trace that I
believe will allow me to explore the
photographic event of mechanized
production that Walter Benjamin writes
about in the early part of the 20th
century how might we Center the
production of photography by considering
the import and utility of black
subjectivity within the project of
empire this is a question for
photography studies and post-colonial
black studies and it will be the main
intervention of my work in the popular
imaginary concerning this series of
decades photographic images solidify the
stark binary logic placing black South
Africans outside the orientation of
self-possession and of sovereignty in
2012 the International Center of
photography in New York City opened an
exhibition rise and fall of apartheid
photography and the bureaucracy of
everyday life the exhibit featured an
art piece by Hans Hockney with a
post-mortem photograph of political
activist Steve Biko
I think it's an autopsy photograph the
center image of a triptych Biko's dead
body is bracketed by images of living
vibrant stage performers from the
Montreal Opera they are as alive in the
photographs as Beco is dead though
certainly a protest image this is called
Boise elk on Boise elk on is also
visually reproducing the violence that
it seeks to indict in order to highlight
the constancy of black death against its
binary variable of white life
documentary images even when in art
productions offer black suffering as a
way to understand the aftermath of
Empire so when I saw the exhibition at
the ICP I sat across from that piece for
quite a while because I I'm trying to
make sense of it I wasn't familiar with
the artist I had to do some research
around that and it was one of I'm not
sure how many images were were shown for
that exhibition it was one of maybe 85 a
hundred images that were that graphic
presented in the museum and there were
no images of white people were they were
they it was like a scene of a series of
very peaceful encounters an occasional
group of white people would be
protesting apartheid other than that
only black people were being violated by
1994 South Africa exists within the
structures of a photographic imaginary
as a symbolic register of work that is
presumed to be going smoothly or coming
to an end you would say in the latter
half of the year the new nation being
reformulated considers what it might
mean for a white minority to be on the
margins of the visible sphere of
political power conversations about the
reconfiguration of the national flag the
falling of monuments the renaming of
streets and bridges fill the op-ed pages
in the New York Times and a lot of these
op eds
say things like and we can't name every
bridge Mandela bridge and we can't name
every street in Mandela Street so
they're trying to figure out what to do
next
in terms of naming
photographs are dis invented disinvested
of the previous racial tensions famously
accompanying media outlets and words
replace imagery so lots and lots of lots
of objects but even this has a past at a
past tense in a 1976 photograph by Peter
Madhubani two women stand near the left
of the center of the frame of the
photograph they orient the eye of the
viewer the center contains no body but
there is a body on the ground someone no
longer alive but occupying space wrapped
in plaid blankets and each exposing one
hand that emerges through the sleeve of
space the blanket provides women stand
someone has died the evening before this
early morning shot was taken one woman
is turned away from the body one is
turned in the direction of the body she
looks down and over the violence of the
evening before is both indexable and
evidentiary three men frame the outer
edges of the photograph providing it
with corporeal marked margins sorry one
on the left and two on the right one of
the men attends to the body on the
ground one gazes back at the
photographer the last man turns his gaze
away from both ocular possibilities
together their bodies Center the two
rows of women encased within the
boundary of the image 10 people 9 living
one day the inverse truth Courtney our
Baker writes that bodies that are looked
at are also bodies that look is an
important understanding in fact this
image is a circular conundrum of
photographic meaning it is movement and
stillness distance and proximity shadow
and light and doesn't exists in a
newspaper at this time in the photograph
we see an archive at work and it is an
image that frames the intent of an
empire within a nation invisible though
it may seem it is a scene of temporal
fluidity an intertextual vision of the
layering of black subjectivity each of
the people present attends or avoids the
sight of the body the body itself is a
problem its placement in the foreground
of the image its status among the dead
and its presence in close proximity to
those gathered about it as the photo
intimates the space between blackness
and death
is too often negotiated by those who are
precarious themselves if we think about
the intersection of race violence and
photography codifying black
subjectivities within and beyond the
framework of the corporeal the role of
the witness is of particular importance
the viewer of for instance newspaper
imagery as an after witness yields to
the on-site witness of the violence
taking place the people photographed
alongside the maimed and injured their
bodies providing the extended
envisioning of projected removal I want
to think about the containment of space
within these photographs as a
solidification of racialized violence
violence that is part of the imagistic
archive producing and extending the
cartography of interest and difference
violence that is as prevalent
photographically as it is resistant to
its own unpacking this often marks the
temporal temporal conflation as it is
rendered here as pre post and
neo-colonial inventing a lineage of
similar imagery across disparate
locations framed to invoke the slippery
nature of other people's sovereignty in
the colonial world France pennant
laments the emotional sensitivity of the
native is kept on the surface of his
skin like an open sore this open sore is
rendered visually as a reproduced
documented I'm sorry as Reaper
this is rendered visually as reproduced
documented assaults against black flesh
and it is this sore that photography has
the ability to reopen and infect a
visual a visual tether of unblocking
joins the men and women in this image to
the person who's just recently passed
from life to death and this is what
renders the photographic scene with its
taut emotive extension not one person in
the image will voluntarily cross the
threshold of this death stop being
inches away from the body they address
it as its own cruel visual display they
both recognize and resist the
demarcation the photographic fungibility
and the imprint of too many implications
of temporal duress this scene blankets
the Mago Bonnie photograph with
constituency's as black subjectivity
takes on the veil of witnessing crowding
out the space between each of the
figures in the photograph while also
closing in on the borders of the photo
and creating an insular space this is
the mechanism through which black South
Africans are asked to register a
legibility of citizenship even as
removal is taking on both literal and
metaphorical dimensions within state
sanctioned violence and subjection there
is the desire for participatory
engagement rendered visually photographs
aid in this arrangement and this is just
one example of the difference between
how black people are presented in Time
magazine and how white people are
presented in Time magazine with the same
within the same time frame and at the
same apartheid structure here we see the
first synthesis between Massacre and
bureaucracy rights a shield and Bembe
and his essay Negro politics that
incarnation of Western rationality
Maharani plays on the texture of this
demarcation between Massacre and
bureaucracy playing itself out in the
townships outside of Johannesburg in the
60s in the seventies life and death
movement and stillness proximity and
distance shadows falling on earth
everything converges in this image
clashes actually as it appears the
photograph subjects mark the visual
dissonance with the distance of their
bodies away and apart from that of the
decedent but close enough to register
register the collective interior T of
this loss the signification of
transnational blackness and documentary
form and this is my project is prior to
September 11th because it changes kind
of drastically after September 11th was
one that invited a vision of corporeal
obliteration fetishized it
photographically and released the
imagery as an ocular engagement
recognizably compelling to a mass
audience already racially protected the
viewers investment extends the
proliferation of the mains or contained
black world subject offering the viewer
to slaughter with the eye those who have
been visually slaughtered out of time so
when uprising is a photograph
of temporal conflation and elongation an
image of the witness the voyeur
and the victim a photograph of blurring
visual constituencies the figure the
subject the pawn in the temporal
demarcation of 1976 when this photograph
is taken we can also imagine the
repetition of 1960 in the Sharpeville
massacre in 1994 the end of apartheid we
left live in an era
Ariella oscillate contends in which is
difficult to conceive of one single
human activity that does not use
photography or at least provide an
opportunity for it to be deployed in the
past present or future the subjects in
the photograph managed the visual
dissonance of a dead body and enact past
present and future in one frame the past
includes the Sharpeville massacre the
present Vista uprising in the future
anticipates the demise of the system of
apartheid in South Africa in 1994
there's a disturbing history of
photographic violence attending black
subjects throughout the African Diaspora
and within the African continent
in the u.s. these images conjure up a
cartography of unbel awning placing dead
black bodies at the center of a
photographic divide from the space of
the gaze the viewer participates and
what in what wjt Mitchell calls the
ocular violence of racism by observing
photographic display of disjuncture
maharani's photograph parses out the
articulations of gender that are not
always present in the available archive
the veneer of safety within a category
of underlying cannot sustain itself here
we know that an absence of acknowledged
inflictions of violence blanket the
imagery involving black women doing
damage to their subjectivity x' this
photograph framed through the two women
standing closest to the body marks this
precise proximity and its gendered
pronouncement as central to the
compensation composition of the image as
the women are central to the framework
of violence and removal situated within
this space of national violence Maha
Bonnie's image details the illustration
of violated bodies that by the state in
1976
become part and parcel of the haunting
of colonial and postcolonial
photographic practices the photographer
framing the site does so after state
imposed imprisonment violations of
citizenship and financial financial
sanctions he says he spends he spent a
total of 586 days in solitary he's
repeatedly arrested he spent six months
in ordinary jail and he says he spent
five years as a ghost's of five years he
could not take any photographs at all he
was forbidden and he was never convicted
of any crime locating his professional
isolation juridical remove mminton
within the elongated structure of South
Africa's temporal shifts Mago Bonney
marks time through the containing
register of a silenced visual archive
his own and this is now the property of
the ICP in New York they own this
photograph and so may be a theory of
photographic distrust is born here out
of three centuries of the visual culture
of racial hegemony a space of black
exceptionality combining Orlando
Patterson's articulation of Natal
alienation with Charles mills and Cydia
Hartman's delineation of the borders of
black citizenship in the symbolic
register a photo of the photographic
imaginary the Empire still holds sway
Frantz Fanon writes this explosive
population growth those hysterical
masses those blank faces those shapeless
bodies these children who seem not to
belong to anyone all this forms part of
the colonial vocabulary what Cydia
Hartman refers to as the slipperiness of
empathy within the structural resonance
of American slavery has Paul Gilroy's
version of post-colonial melancholia at
its core and in that slippage Cristina
sharp maintains is also the multiple
ways that oppressive social systems
apartheid ethnocentrism and slavery
drive people in all places in the power
structure mad in this madness
there are the unstated performative
deployments of projected rage poised and
perfected for nearly 200 photographic
years I'm interested in the visuality of
this deployment a visuality
that has its lens
turned toward the proliferation of
specific pained and nonliving subjects
and the racial aftermath of this
indifference in these moments of
carnivorous voyeurism we allow the image
to culturally inform the very thing we
see regardless of the medium through
which we see it what the camera does
John Berger argues and what the eye
itself can never do is fix the
appearance of that event it removes its
appearance from the flow of appearances
and it preserves it not perhaps for ever
but for as long as the film exists if we
were to negotiate the terms of not
perhaps forever there would be a
distinct racial dialogue that routinely
places blackness outside the periphery a
photographic citizenship but my interest
lingers here where two women stand near
the left of the center of the frame of
the photograph and orient the eye of the
viewer the center contains no body but
there is a body on the ground someone no
longer alive but occupying space this is
a photograph of shadows on earth of the
singular mandates and imperatives they
find their way into an image whether the
viewer sees a body a subject a figure an
empire or the faint outline of the
imprint of loss
[Applause]
okay so the bang-bang club is a group of
South African photographers who are
known for entering date dangerous areas
and therefore that's how they get the
name so the casualty of the bangbang
club is because they see a lot they
photograph a lot and they're always in a
space of danger and so the idea is that
they don't there are two of them who are
still alive of the four or five who were
in the group yeah so they're semi-famous
there's a movie about them I think it's
called a baby
[Music]
okay okay I'll start with the if I can
with with this image so I presented not
this image but the actual archive I'm
working with and I have to decide
whether or not I show the image I
decided I'm not going to put them in the
book so I'm less and less comfortable
actually presenting them so I showed one
with the body cropped out it's a series
of women it's in it's in port-au-prince
and it's women and they're all dressed
in white and they're standing around a
body and they're they're anguished I
left that and I cut off the body to do
the presentation and a photographer was
at that conference it was a I think it
was called I can't really doing
photography conference so the
photographer said use the image or don't
use the image don't crop it so as a
photographer he said you know use it or
don't use it but don't do this but I
couldn't find a way to negotiate when I
was attempting to say and for how long I
was attempting to say it and and to
leave the body even a body that's
covered up for 10 20 15 minutes so I
have been cropping when I do this so
this this one in particular I wanted to
just isolate all of people instead of
having the entire image structure
different since I already had that I
wanted to isolate the people and their
separate spaces the spaces that they
occupy in the photograph so I don't
always do this but I definitely end up
cropping out the body for the Claudia
Rankine image Rankine asked Getty who
owns this image if she could have
somebody crop out the bodies at first
they didn't they didn't want the image
to be
Jews they were hesitant they didn't know
what she was going to do with it and
then they allowed her to have someone
crop out the bodies so I've been using
this because it's just an easier image
to speak through without the bodies
present and because it's so famous the
bodies I think I'm not necessary there
so I'm not sure how the person that she
hired to do that
did that work but that's what she had
right and then she had to ask permission
to cut the bodies out because they
didn't want alter I wonder if that maybe
that was a consideration for the press
and not as much her I'm not sure I just
heard her speak about it at a talk
about two years ago there was a show of
VR work and the three spherical video on
360 video in several several of pieces
one in particular was a 360 video
documentary piece
that was
it was about
right right so I have this conversation
recently with graduate students at Emory
we had a seminar on problematic archives
and so I don't think for instance that
the Carter image should not have been
made I do think that more of a
consideration for the humanity of the
subject in the photograph especially
after the fact should have taken place
the students talked about the civil
rights museum having apparently you can
go to a counter sit down and experience
someone beating you harassing you
it's the experience is duplicated and
the goal is to see how long you can sit
with the machine on feel
everything as as if it is taking place
so the conversation was about a few of
them had gone my intention is to
eventually go to rights museum I don't
know if I will do this but they said it
was odd
it felt both false like you at all times
you know you're safe and they didn't
know what it was for
so again when I said at the beginning I
don't know what the solution is I would
not know how to produce how to reproduce
this narrative that is a traumatic
narrative how to represent it and then
how to make people feel both
uncomfortable and comfortable in a
spatial configuration so I don't know
that I would do it that way I think
that's probably not the best way to do
it because again the much more subtle
version of like getting a non-white card
or a white card and then entering the
museum and two doors side-by-side and
you end up in the same space it's a
completely other side I don't think
people know what to do so I will
probably go to the lynching Museum I
want to see how that's done I'm not sure
from the images because it's like I'm
not sure what are they are they like
long and they're hanging from the
ceiling because you know how would the
lynching Museum how would it look if
they try to duplicate bodies hanging
that would not work right but then how
do you like get to the totality of the
event and its ongoing implications
without doing something that's gonna
make people feel really uncomfortable so
that is to say I wouldn't say that's the
way that I would go but I mean the new
technologies I'm concerned about that
but I don't know I don't know about the
other side of this as well even archival
work is also kind of damaging so we
discussed the zealey photographs the
daguerreotype sort the interest set of
images not the set of images that were
made that Harvard now owns
that I've been released basically
everywhere and that now and you know
these are of enslaved people and you
could knock information and the images
to me are not images it should be shown
everywhere again not to say that I'm
opposed to the fact that they exist but
why they're being shown why they're
being duplicated show them the cover of
the book
Delia's tears and like why do you have a
slave woman on the cover why is it book
called Delia's tears what are we
supposed to do with that I don't know
right so that's all say I don't have the
answer but I don't know who has the
answer thank you
[Music]
right yes so I I also hear that a lot
and I was a graduate student when I went
to I think it was called thinking
photography again conference and there
were a lot of photo journalists there
and part of the conversation was what
role does the photographer have in some
of these images in their production and
you can't control where they move after
you release them to a news media agency
my question is always what is the
evidence that white people die they die
but we would not present it in a
newspaper or a magazine that way no
matter what the circumstance and I'm
talking about basically the United
States right so even after September
11th when people jumped off of the out
of windows right you could see those
images now they're really hard to find
you can't even make out who they are but
you know they're white because you have
seen them circulating that's how I know
that way so so that's that's what I have
to say about that and and we do know for
instance why people are killed by the
police you've not seen these images have
you seen these images you're not seeing
these images they wouldn't show these
images why wouldn't they show these
images because that's not what we do
here but we do show images of black
people always a default register and
then after September 11th its South
Asian Arab anybody who can be read as
Middle Eastern or so we do that so after
September 11th this is a completely
different argument I couldn't do that
project that's somebody else's project
but there's like a proliferation the
child who ended up on the shore I saw
that photograph as the image used for a
conference at the University of
Pennsylvania would you see that if that
child were registered as white would
that be a thing you know that we would
do that we would see
I haven't seen it so far I'm still
waiting to so that's usually that's
that's my only response if you have a
repeated engagement that is severely
one-sided people are very much used to
black people dying that's why the videos
now don't shock people as much as like
you're really watching a snuff film
but you're also watching the news and I
don't know how that can be reconciled
and I don't see that for any other group
of people and again police officers war
fires famine murders all these things
take place but that's not how the
archive is constructed right yes right
yeah it's all interconnected right
like right exactly yeah so there's so
much in the archive that has to do with
black people being so close to death
that it you know it's just it's
imminently it's on its way and we don't
have that for people and again white
people die
snobby they don't die it's not the same
level of precarity it's nit it's not
equal in any way but there are way more
white people in this country so why do
we have such a small archive of anything
that looks like they're their bodies
being violated in any way visually it's
something that would not take place the
woman who is a woman who's on the scene
during the Newtown Sunita so children
Connecticut yes she has rolls of film
she's taking photographs as people as
people are carrying children out there
injured they are dead and you have never
seen them and you will never see them
and not because they're children because
we know that's not a dividing line for
other people right you'll never see them
because you're not supposed to see them
slow motion and all the photos I've seen
the white bodies but I wonder if I'm
missing something
there's also I mean all those images
were about raised on some level given
what war was about but I wonder if
there's also an archive of black bodies
during the Civil War that has non
circulated perhaps because the tragedy
of the Civil War
so it begin there because I'm mildly
obsessed with photographs in the Civil
War I ask people who work on this
archive photographic archive if they had
seen any photographs of African American
soldiers in uniform on battlefields just
that I asked if it's seen and they were
so few of them on battlefields in
uniform and and then I asked if they had
seen any of these images of dead
soldiers if any of them were black so
far nothing went to the Library of
Congress and put in my little search I
put it in african-american soldiers
Civil War and the Library of Congress
actually says so we don't have a whole
lot on this and then it says and even if
we did it'd be hard to tell who's black
like who's african-american or not
so in this republic of suffering drew
Gilpin Faust look she talks about how
there's an entire process of producing
or preserving bodies to return to
families during the Civil it gets going
during the Civil War and the number one
thing that they're guaranteeing is that
the body won't turn black I know right I
was like staying here that's something
that's so important so people of means
are making sure that the body is
returned to them and put on ice so it's
like the beginning of like the modern
version of funeral practice that we now
know today but they're promising in
advertisements that the bodies we
promised to return the white body to you
the body will not turn black because and
FASTA saying imagine how horrified
people are to find out that when they're
white when they're white family members
die that they actually turn black during
the Civil War which is right so so I
start there because I was really
interested in the the hyper presence of
dead bodies
a complete almost complete absence of
black soldiers I cannot locate them on a
battlefield in uniform except for a few
very few exceptions and they're usually
digging graves for other for white
soldiers or serving officers those are
those are the photographs we have there
are 1 million photographs from this from
that archive from the Civil War so
that's something that I think the
country wasn't willing to have take
place vision so if we were going to
mourn the almost you know destruction of
the country and it's being saved through
the war that cannot happen with black
people they're participating so they're
just not so then I wondered why you know
so at the end of the then you have
reconstruction failing then you have the
series of lynching photographs then you
have so what is the pleasure that's
taking places like why people need to
see black people suffering in order to
deal with having to live around in any
way shape or form African Americans as
fellow citizens and that's what I see
being played out across and so I want to
know what that means at the end of the
20th century when the internet is just
going and when film photography is
ending and digital photography is about
to begin so
so I think I think these images because
there are so many from 94 are supposed
to tell black people something really
precise about how unwanted they are on
the cusp of the 21st century the same
way that lynching photographs was
supposed to publicly announce how
unwanted black people were the end of
the 19th century on the cusp of the 20th
it's something swifter and it's more
graphic and it's not Americans but there
are plenty of african-americans shown on
the cover of that newspaper as well same
year so something is going on there some
kind of communicate visual communication
yeah
yes yeah that's a good point that is a
really good point so yeah that's a good
point
because I have not decided I haven't
decided for myself what gets included
and what definitely doesn't get included
but the images that I am looking at
there are no white people around it's
just black people but it's moving
through you know white newspaper spaces
with an assumed white viewer here I'm so
for me this image is it isolates the
crowd and what's striking to me is that
in all of the lynching photographs and
all of the lynching postcards in all of
these images not one family member has
been found nobody's claiming their kin
this is the 19th century this is the
early 20th century these people existed
they mailed these postcards to their
family members nobody is saying that's
my uncle that's my cousin that's my
grandfather
I know sign these people cuz I you know
they can be found right you have people
coming out of minds completely covered
in foot and people like milk that is my
great uncle Jerry and they can't find
any of nobody of claiming any of these
people that is really striking to me so
if you're gonna do something so bold so
brazen so violent so public but you know
you never have to be found out and you
know the generations later you would
never be found that's very America to me
and that's something worth
exploring so I haven't figured out
because I think I'm at the point where I
can not show anymore lynching
photographs and and also National
african-american museum history culture
has such a long acronym the African
American History Museum
they have Emmett Till casket you know
what I hear from black people who go to
the museum I only hear about that casket
it's a lot of conversation about what to
do about this thing that is apparently
behind screen I haven't gone yet it's
behind a screen but they're like should
I bring my child
you know everybody feels traumatized
what do you do I think it's an
interesting choice I wouldn't choose it
I wouldn't put that in the museum to
represent Emmett Till but that's what
they did now what do you do with that
right yeah right so we're back to the
evidentiary question we know what
happened people have told stories black
people have passed around these
narratives they know what happened
everybody knows what happened what's
going to be done based on what evidence
is being presented I don't think it's
surprised or shocked anyone I think we
have a high tolerance or white
aggression and I think we have a low
tolerance for black life and that
combination is really where we are now
so it wouldn't matter I don't know what
the solution is but show her don't show
it wouldn't matter at first I said I was
going to show only the cover of the New
York Times cuz I'm like that's you know
you can get that anywhere but some of
those covers are show them you wouldn't
believe that they would present a person
who just died that way what they do so
now I don't want to do that
what happened
the photograph and Patil in his casket
that his mother his mother insisted the
casket be opened so that he could be
seen right and I think that was not just
to be seen by people who were at the
service so for that I would point out
Sandy Alexander has a reading of Emmett
Till's photograph and the other
photographs that he the casket is open
she agrees to have that photographed and
moves across right moves internationally
but there are also photographs in the
coffin of him not in that state so it's
all part of a conversation I think the
the museum said that Mamie till wanted
the casket to be in the museum that's
their statement but there was supposed
to be an Emmett Till Museum and that's
where I was supposed to go so you know
taken out of that context how does that
because it makes sense for an amateur
museum but not something to me not so
much in that space sandy so I don't I
don't really work on until as much so
what I do I understand what she was
attempting to do there but again show
the image don't show the image and it's
still gonna be when people ask a
question about evidence I say
testimonies evidence and black people
are always willing to tell you what
happened to them and people don't
believe testimony given in court by the
people who have been harmed
so I don't know what you know we have
video footage now people get acquitted I
don't know what we're supposed to what
what would work so yes and no so the
example I use is Michael Brown is
murdered he's laying in the ground for
four hours it's Twitter that's the
reason we know what happened it's 1
million tweets in New York Times tracks
1 million tweets over four days before
news media outlets cover this without
the tweets we still wouldn't know what
happened and if people are on the ground
they were tweeting they're saying you
won't believe this and you know the
image is moving really swiftly after a
while Brown's parents asked people to
stop showing showing his body in the
ground but by then enough tweets have
gone out and then it becomes something
that can't be ignored so in that way it
does connect to the way that Mamie till
was like you you know I'm gonna let
people see what she did to my child if
she had said I'm not going to let you
let anybody see this I don't know that
the civil rights movement would not have
still like they like Emmett Till is it's
a force with or without I think the
photographs although it reached reaches
internationally you know it moves in a
way that the United States responds not
right now response to international
shame and that work during the civil
rights movement especially with the u.s.
trying to tell Soviet Union how to be a
better democracy and they they have
evidence to say this is what you do to
your own City
so I don't know I think there is a
moment photographically where things
that were possible then become too much
to be contained but there's still a
similar reaction like you still cannot
get most people to do what it takes so I
people routinely say that they can't
bear to see these images that are
sitting on the cover of the New York
Times or they've been out there is not
one it's like hundreds and and then I
want to know what that looks like do you
write a letter to the editor do you
refuse to buy the newspaper do you do
you call your senator no people just say
I can't bear it you can bear it because
clearly it's still happening and now
that we have like so many moving images
I don't think this is going to stop
anytime soon there's definitely an
audience for it and it doesn't seem to
to matter how much how much trauma black
people have to absorb in order for this
information to be presented so I don't
that is all say I don't have an answer I
don't know what you do but I don't think
I have to show the images in order to
and there are also for the New York
Times plenty of images where people
aren't dead but they're like the girl
and the vulture not dead but
mm-hmm really oh is that so
so that's Wow that's really profound cuz
you really don't see that I think yeah
that would go a really long way Wow see
now I really have to go because I want
to see a place that makes me think this
is one way to do it where it could
possibly work and it means you know
so if African Americans are going to be
traumatized and they are then white
people need to feel uncomfortable - they
can't roll through I think the apartheid
museum is it's a pleasurable experience
for white people is no there's nothing
there it's very orderly it's like
apartheid system then it ends and it was
over and that's not what it was and the
photographs that everybody else received
don't say that it was
oh wow wow that yeah it's so right it's
not yeah
so I'd hurt I see people on Twitter
saying I wonder if my
great-grandfather's name is there that's
like that's a really different
engagement than you know going to visit
say and it tells the symbolic register
of Emmett Till's casket
Oh
cardboard murders and the gym factory
right right
and I wonder who who goes to this Museum
and they were just open but yeah yeah I
think that's probably my next step yeah
I think I need to visit I think I need
to go there that makes sense that makes
both visual political and cultural sense
to me this is another kind of immersive
experience where you know you really do
have to sit with it that's what I I
didn't find so much in the part time
Yeah right essentially right
precisely that's a great question so I
so I kind of like Baldwin's quote about
white naivete you know he says like
white people have your looped in their
naivete they won't grow up
you can't move like you're both locked
in the same space but that's because
white people will not culturally grow up
and acknowledge what has been taking
place in their own country I think
that's what this does it doesn't give
white people the sense that they don't
die but it does give them a sense that
their lives absolutely matter when they
do and that's a completely different
relationship to to their political
social spaces this is why people are
calling the cops about it like this is
why this is what that looks like because
I can't say on Twitter but I suspect
that for some of them they want to see a
scene of violence and death and they
want to be at the center of that like
they want to see a black person arrested
a black person you know wrestled to the
ground a black person kicked or a black
person shot or why are you calling the
police because they're around is it
because you think you're entitled to
that level of surveillance is it some
kind of performance that you need to see
I don't know but there's a level of
desire there that is about both refusal
and then that looping naivete where
nobody gets to breathe really
I think that's what it does because it's
inexplicable to me so I've given
presentations on the actual newspaper
images and I met with disbelief like why
people don't believe that there are no
white people in the cover the New York
Times and but if they were there I would
have already had the names and the dates
like of all of those moments when they
exist you know in the cover
that's how infrequently I don't think
it'll be the case that they're never
there I think it's so infrequent and it
might as well but it's black people are
not generally like oh no that's that's
so shocking white people are like why
there is no how is that possible that's
that's the naivete that black people
have to live in which is why it just
keeps looping around and that's what I
think these images
thank you
[Applause]